Last time on True Fear, I talked about how
I pretty much almost died on the subway.
If you haven’t seen that one, I will take
pity on you, and leave you a link so you can
go check that out.
And as I mentioned in the last one, I live
in LA now but I’m a Chicago guy and I love
my Cubs.
For those of you who don’t know, Harry Caray
was one of the most legendary Cubs TV broadcasters
in the 80s and 90s to the point where he’s
become an icon, in fact the stadium now has
video boards upon which they frequently have
Harry lead the 7th inning stretch at Wrigley.
For some reason, pretty much all Chicago sports
legends have their own steakhouse.
You’ve got Walter Payton’s Roundhouse,
Ditka’s Restaurant, Michael Jordan’s Steakhouse
and of course, Harry Caray’s Italian Steakhouse,
which is where today’s story begins.
Shall we dig right in?
Sorry for that pun.
So the year was 2012 and I had just graduated
from High School.
It was August, so that summer was winding
down, and some of us were on the way to college
in the next couple of weeks, so we wanted
to get together for one last dinner, and we
had never really been anywhere nice before
so we thought it would be cool to hit up the
legendary Harry Caray’s.
At the front of the restaurant, there is this
bust of the man himself and on the wall you
see all the pictures of celebrities who have
been to the restaurant posing with the bust.
We decide to get a group photo around it.
So that was it.
We take the photo, get out of there, and go
home.
… OK, but there’s more.
At some point the photo gets uploaded onto
Facebook, right?
Eight days later, one of the guys… we’ll
just call him Sheik, leaves the following
comment:
“hey Roman, is that your hand on my left
shoulder?
cuz it looks like translucent”
To which he replied:
“I honestly don't know if that's my hand
haha”
Sheik replies: “doesnt it look alittle strange
tho?
its like transparent”
Then I notice an interesting detail.
“There's a ring on it... it isn't any of
us…”
We’re all 18 at this point and none of us
are married.
Plus just look at us, clearly none of us are
married, OK I’m done.
Done.
Then Roman brings up that it could be like
a class ring but his hand is straight down
by his side.
And you can clearly tell by the angle of where
he is that you would see his wrist if it was
him.
The next comment reads: “If I had to guess,
it kind of looks like Mr. Boathouse’s...
Or the floating hand from the Adam's family”.
Well, first of all dude, it’s called The
Adams Family, not Adam’s Family.
Second of all, the possibility of it being
Mr. Boathouse’s hand is probably the most
likely explanation at this point, but I honestly
don’t believe that it’s him based on distance
and the angle of his hand.
Even if he was able to reach that far, his
hand would be more pointed to the left hand
side of the photo.
Plus, something comes up later to prove that
it wasn’t him.
I’ll get back to that.
This guy thinks that it’s Bailor’s hand,
but that doesn’t make sense, so I say, “Bailor’s
hands are on Roman's left shoulder and Mr
Boathouse’'s right shoulder.
It can't be Bailor.”
So his next suggestion just reiterates the
possibility that it’s Mr. Boathouse’s
hand.
That’s when Sheik reveals how he first noticed
the mysterious hand.
He writes this: “its not, hes the one who
noticed and questioned the hand on my shoulder”
So basically that’s not any of our hands.
My hands both seem to be in my pockets, and
besides, it’s only my left hand that is
concealed.
That’s a right hand on Sheik’s shoulder.
ADDITIONAL “EVIDENCE”
So I came up with the theory that the ghost
of Harry Caray wanted to get in on our photo.
This was 2012 it was the worst Cubs season
in over 40 years.
They lost over 100 games that year, so it
makes sense that Harry’s ghost would be
especially restless.
It’s also been said that in Game 7 of the
World Series in 2016, when the Cubs gave up
the lead and lost their momentum going into
extra innings, that the spirits of Harry Caray,
Ernie Banks and Ron Santo came together to
cause the rain delay that gave the team time
to recuperate and come out swinging with everything
on the line in the 10th.
If you found this story entertaining, and
you’d be willing to go ahead and drop me
a like on this video, that would be much appreciated.
Be sure to leave your own theory, down in
the comments.
For the next True Fear, I’ll probably do
that follow up video on The Hobo King.
Let me know if you guys still want to see
that.
I’ve been talking to some different people
who have their own stories about creepy stuff
going down in that apartment complex and they
said that they’d be willing to come on the
show and talk about it so be sure to subscribe
to CZsWorld for new horrors every week,
ring that death-bell for notifications.
Aaand yeah.
I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming, we both survive.